you talk to me often about how you know
the world's changing quickly its
changing quickly for all of us and you
talk about struggling with technology
we've talked about this before and this
is an ongoing struggle for you yeah like
I have about 11,000 unopened emails
mm-hmm
because I just think oh I mean after a
month they call you don't you think yeah
you know yeah you they tried to show me
how to do it and the worst is the phone
I have iPhone 8 and I'm only qualified
for the two I'm only I can do very
little but I do have one thing that I'll
tell you what to get I have an OB phone
Kenobi you know that friend who can fix
a phone yes
I'll be phone yeah and then they take
the phone and tune tune in or tune in or
when you get older all the words aren't
available yeah I request a turn in and
tune in came down yeah your heads like
that 8-ball thing you got a shaker right
try again later Louie and they get the
phone and they are like oh for God's
sakes you've got everything open on here
do i I didn't know that you got this
open that's open Dairy Queen finder
really Louie here are the Dairy Queen
finder well I love a dilly bar
[Applause]
and they're not they ask you that when's
the last time you back this up what you
even know how to back it up Louie I'm
terrible with all that stuff but but
have an OB phone Kenobi it really does
yeah you got to have someone for me it's
my son my son understand right stuff
he's 13 young takes on my phone I don't
know how to do anything and he's like ah
and we're like hack into the Pentagon
you know and they shame you about it oh
Jesus dad come on
yeah you know so yeah I just got out I
go I mean I didn't know I had to close
up Amazon where I lock you know with
those apps I didn't know they closed
down yeah yeah no you got to close it up
I had no idea yeah at 11,000 apps open
moving about as fast as I do